a lot of people in your profession who
wax poetically for weeks and weeks about
our Florida was going to be just like
New York not only do we have a lower
death rate while we have way lower
deaths generally we have a lower death
rate than the Acela Quarter we've
succeeded and I think that people just
don't want to recognize it because it
challenges their narrative it challenges
their assumption so they got to try to
find a boogeyman
well that was Florida Governor Ron de
santis they're blasting the media as you
just heard for its coverage of his
state's coronavirus response to sand
just pointing out the media's dire
predictions about Florida's reopening
never materializing dan Henninger is a
Wall Street Journal editorial page
deputy editor a Fox News contributor Wow
I mean he made a lot of headlines
standing there next to the vice
president touting the data coming from
his state saying it is clearly
challenging the partisan narrative that
is out there what do you think Dan well
I thought Governor De Santis certainly
had a point there's a lot of partisan
narratives going on here and one that
Ron DeSantis is well aware of is that
he's aligned or thought to be aligned
with President Trump ergo he's public
enemy number one with the media that
part is simple there's another narrative
though which is that broke out around
the corona virus which is that
Republican governors whether it was Ron
de Santos or Brian Kemp in Georgia Greg
Abbott in Texas the feeling was that
Republicans were anti science and
where's the idea of anti science come
from it comes from another apocalypse
which is climate change the idea
developed that anyone who is a skeptic
about climate change was anti science
now we've got another apocalypse in the
Qura in the corona virus and the media
has equated total lockdowns with what
all science knows but we know there's a
lot we don't know about the corona virus
and kovat and I think Ron de santis and
some of these other governors by being
skeptical about total lockdowns
have shown that we indeed do not know as
much as we should about transmission
rates the media really did kind of make
New York City which has had a horrible
experience has made
New York kind of the standard for the
rest of the country which it is that
simply is not pulling no punches citing
data from the White House he said quote
we have succeeded possibly is this
victory lap a little bit too soon till
we see how this all plays out dan well
we do have to see how it plays out
through the summer and into the fall but
bear in mind the reason for the
lockdowns originally was to allow the
hospital system to handle it to prevent
it from collapsing and that by and large
has been achieved around the country and
I don't think there's any question there
will continue to be coronavirus
infections people will be admitted to
hospitals but it does appear that the
hospital system in Florida is going to
be able to handle the volume of
coronavirus cases they receive while the
rest of the economy gets back to
business want to get to your piece in
The Wall Street Journal this morning
your op-ed titled Elon Musk's final
straw in it you talked about Nancy
Pelosi offering not a bailout but a bail
in a nationalization of blue state
spending you talk about her your words
mind-numbing three trillion-dollar
coronavirus legislation you say the best
way to comprehend that is to draw a
straight line from Elon Musk to the
House Democratic caucus in Washington
explain well Elon Musk famously tweeted
last week that Gavin Newsome the
authorities in California said he could
not open his Tesla factory out there and
he said that was the last straw he's
trying to compete with other automakers
and in Detroit and what he meant was
that California has just had a cast